on sait les panneaux solaires permettent
de produire de l'énergie mais permettent
également de dessaler l'eau de mer
la technologie a été mise au point par
une entreprise basée près de chartres
elle a été créée il ya deux ans elle
s'appelle lascars à l'eau l'eau douce
c'est le problème numéro un du mann heat
et 40% de la population mondiale
souffrent de stress hydrique et pourtant
sur la planète bleue
l'eau est partout mais elle est surtout
salle et là des salles et c'est possible
mais à l'aide d'énergies fossiles cela
revient très cher et c'est très polluant
la grande nouvelle c'est qu'une
alternative existe désormais cette
petite entreprise de charte en effet
inventé le dessalement de l'eau de mer
par l'énergie solaire
ici on a une réserve d'eau de mer qui
qui est disponible qui va entrer donc
dans la machine au travers de pré filtre
et qui va ensuite rejoindre la pompe
haute pression qui va envoyer dans les
membranes les membranes sont contenues
dans ses portes membrane blanc là que
vous voyez ici on va envoyer l'eau de
mer sous pression dans ses portes
membrane l'eau va franchir avec une
pression très importante de l'ordre de
60 bars l'ensemble de ces membranes et
va ressortir de l'autre côté en eau
douce d'une part qui va être utilisable
et en os sur sané qui elle va retourner
à la mer l'eau sur sale et contient
encore une pression importante et nous
avons ici un récupérateur d'énergie qui
nous permet de récupérer la pression de
l'eau sur saleh pour injecter de l'eau
de mer
neuf dans les membranes sous pression ça
nous permet de réduire de manière
importante la consommation spécifique de
notre installation et ça nous permet
d'être optimale avec l'utilisation de
capteurs solaires de ce grand produit
nous avons fait un petit produit pour
toutes les situations d'urgence cette
unité de 10 mètres cubes jour peut être
installé en 48 heures à n'importe quel
endroit dans le monde
et puis enfin on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait un énorme besoin pour le
traitement d'eau saumâtre et nous avons
inventé cette unité qui part au
mozambique
la grande unité elle partira en janvier
prochain sur l'île de rodrigues qui à
600 km au nord-est de l'île maurice
meurent de soif
au milieu de son somptueux lagon et
besoins sont de 12 mille mètres cubes
d'eau par jour et là on va installer une
unité de 80 mètres cubes jour qui va
fonctionner au fil du soleil
et pour après si ça fonctionne ça va
fonctionner en australie installera
plusieurs unités les plus grandes
les plus grands noms peu partout dans
l'île vraiment stressé oui il ya un
énorme stress hydrique ils ont 3 3h02
d'eau par jour
donc c'est vraiment ils comptent sur
nous et on compte sur eux pour nous
aider à feuilles et le marché est
immense parce que les besoins sont
immenses
mascara c'est le nom de la pme shirt
rennes s'est associé à de plus grosses
entreprises pour s'implanter à travers
la planète
aujourd'hui avec le changement
climatique et la croissance
démographique et compte tenu du prix de
l'énergie solaire qui diminuent
constamment et a de plus en plus de
zones pour lequel le dessalement solaire
serait complètement pertinents donc on
pense notamment à des régions comme
comme le pacifique où on intervient avec
avec suez où le meut l'asie du sud-est
où on est avec akio avec masdar au
moyen-orient ou encore dans les îles de
l'océan indien l'afrique du sud qui
subit aussi des sécheresse sans
précédent
le cap vers la caraïbe aussi où il ya
des îles dans lesquels l'eau vient à
manquer et coûte très cher lorsqu'elle
est d'aider salé à partir d'énergies
fossiles et mascara est l'objet de
grandes intentions de la part des géants
mondiaux de l'eau parce qu'elle est la
seule entreprise à voir bref c'est un
procédé qui allie eau de mer et soleil
pour produire de l'eau douce comme elle
l'a fait notamment à bora bora un petit
coin de paradis au large de tahiti
nous sommes ici sur le toit d'un
entrepôt logistique à bourges sur l'une
des plus importantes installations
solaires de la région six mille mètres
carrés de panneaux installés
laurent édition vous avez combien de
sites comme celui ci dans la région
centre alors on a ses petites comme
celui ci sur la région centre
au niveau de l'entreprise cadran groupe
direct energie on exploite plus de 150
sites solaires au total et celui ci est
effectivement celui qui est le plus
grand en région centre sur le en termes
de parc solaire en toiture
la toiture fait à peu près 800 kilowatts
de puissance installée et sa production
d'électricité sur l'année correspond à
la consommation d'à peu près 400 foyers
est-ce que c'est rentable oui c'est
encore aujourd'hui le solaire comme
beaucoup d'autres énergies renouvelables
mais le solaire en particulier sur les
nouvelles installations qu'on propose
c'est qu'on installe aujourd'hui en 2018
soit un prix de revient de l'électricité
produite qui est aujourd'hui inférieur à
l'électricité qu'on produirait avec une
nouvelle centrale nucléaire par exemple
inférieurs aux prix qui sortira de la
centrale de flamanville et environ 20 25
% moins cher que des nouvelles
installations thermiques ou des
nouvelles installations nucléaires et
alors pourquoi ça ne voulait pas plus
vite que les stars si ça coûte moins
cher parce que il faut arriver à
accompagner cette ses nouvelles
productions il faut arriver à les
intégrer dans la dans l'exploitation du
réseau national et aussi parce que c'est
une donnée qui est relativement récente
les baisses de prix et les baisses de
coûts de production en solaire
sont issus des progrès techniques qui
ont été faits et de la
l'industrialisation de cette de cette
technologie
et ça ne fait que guère que deux ans à
trois ans que on arrive à des prix aussi
compétitif l'objectif de passer à 50%
d'énergies renouvelables d'ici 2025 a
été positivement avant de venir et
savante mais ce qui pourrait donner un
coup de pouce à ces énergies
renouvelables
c'est la baisse des poux par exemple un
panneau solaire coûte aujourd'hui dix
fois moins cher qu'il ya dix ans